the intricacy of drax's tattoos presents
a challenge they're not quite like
traditional tattoos as they're raised in
a fairly consistent shade of red yet
neither are they as random as battle
damage or as uniform as purposeful body
modification like killmonger's extensive
scars they are like Drax entirely unique
and entirely alien to create them the
makeup artists use 18 prosthetic pieces
placed onto the areas previously mapped
out using skin illustrator and the
plastic mold once applied makeup is used
to blend the Prosthetics into drax's
skin and a fan brush is raked across his
body turning the raised tissue of the
Prosthetics red few aspects of the
outrageous look of the guardian's cast
have presented the special effects team
with more challenges than drax's unique
tattoos and ultimately push them into
ever more impressive levels of
innovation